ich hoffe auf den zusatzpunkt 14 nachdem
wir eben schon den finanzminister gehört
haben so den fragen wie nun jetzt den
menschen geholfen werden kann in dieser
corona pandemie wird sich jetzt auch der
zuständige minister in den bereichen
äußern hubertus heil hier noch mit maske
ist der bundesminister für arbeit und
soziales und wird jetzt hier im neuen
tagesordnungspunkt wo es aber um
ähnliche hilfen geht oder sogar um die
gleichen hilfen geht wird er hier als
erstes sprechen so ich habe die
aussprache unter tage als erstem rede
dem herrn bundesminister hubertus heil
für die bundesregierung das wort
präsident meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren menschen die ohnehin schon wenig
geld haben stehen in der akuten caron
alle situationen vor zusätzlichen
finanziellen belastungen wie lange die
pandemie andauert desto höher werden
diese belastung gerade für bedürftige
menschen
wenn etwa zusätzliche kosten anfallen
sei es sehr gut jetzt zum beispiel für
kinderspielzeug oder für homeschooling
oder desinfektionsmittel oder masken
oder corona schnelltest nicht nur
schulen und kitas sondern auch viele
soziale einrichtungen wie büchereien
schwimmbäder und jugendtreffs
geschlossen sind
das geht für viele menschen die es
ohnehin schon nicht leicht haben mental
und finanziell an die substanz diese
menschen meine damen und herren brauchen
unsere solidarität
denn es ist und muss unser ziel sein
dass wir auch in dieser akuten
gesundheits und wirtschaftskrise die
gesamte gesellschaft zusammenhalten mir
als bundesarbeitsministers geht es um
konkrete hilfen die ankommen
und deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir
zusätzlich zum ohnehin notwendigen
anpassung der regelsätze zum ersten
januar im insgesamt wert von 1,4
milliarden euro jetzt zusätzliche
maßnahmen kurzfristig zur verfügung
stellen
dazu gehört auch angesichts der auf der
vorletzten ministerpräsidentin
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
verschärften auflagen in vieler hinsicht
für medizinische masken dass wir auch
für menschen den grundsicherungssystem
entsprechenden basken zur verfügung
stellen
das ist auf dem weg gemeinsam mit dem
bundesgesundheitsminister sorgen wir
dafür dass menschen
grundsicherungssystem auch die
notwendigen masten bekommen zweitens
zweitens müssen wir angesichts von
verlängerten homeschooling dafür sorgen
dass kinder in der grundsicherung nicht
dadurch ausgeschlossen sind dies ohnehin
ständig leicht haben dass sie keine
digitale endgeräte zum beispiel laptops
drucker oder tablets haben
da hat die bundesregierung bereits im
letzten jahr gehandelt mit 500 millionen
euro aus dem digital packt wir müssen
wir feststellen dass das in vielen
ländern und kommunen nicht entsprechend
umgesetzt wurde und deshalb habe ich auf
basis einer neuen rechtlichen
möglichkeit die gesagt erst im januar
mit dem regelsatz geschaffen haben die
jobcenter angewiesen die kosten für
endgeräte für kinder die keine
leihgeräte oder endgeräte zur verfügung
haben jetzt auch schnell und
unbürokratisch zu übernehmen
drittens geht es aber auch um direkten
finanziellen druck und mit dem heutigen
sozialstaats paket bringen wir
zusätzliche maßnahmen kurzfristig auf
den weg
dazu gehört ein zuschlag auf die
grundsicherung und zwar auf die
verschiedenen grund sicherungssysteme
für erwachsene von jeweils zusätzlich
150 euro und wir werden auch den
kinderbonus einführen der nicht auf die
grundsicherungssystem angerechnet wird
auch noch mal 150 euro oder einem
beispiel für ein ehepaar mit zwei
kindern die beide in der grundsicherung
sind 150 für den wand 150 für die frau
jeweils 150 euro für jedes kind gibt es
viele aus der opposition die sagen das
reicht ich verstehe diese debatte aber
tun sie bitte nicht so als sei das nicht
nichts das hilft den menschen sehr
konkrete spur gegeben
denn meine damen und herren dieser
gesetzentwurf bringt noch eine fülle von
anderen regelungen auf den weg zum
beispiel werden wir den vereinfachten
zugang zur grundsicherung weiter bis zum
ende des jahres verlängern damit
menschen die jetzt auf grundsicherung
angewiesen sind
ob sie selbstständige sind ob sie die
kurzarbeiter sind die ergänzende
grundsicherung brauchen wir uns um
niedrig war oder langzeitarbeitslosen
und menschen sind jetzt auch in
langzeitarbeitslosigkeit kommen nicht
sich gleichzeitig in ihrer not noch
sorgen zum beispiel um die
angemessenheit ihres wohnraums machen
müssen
ein ganz wichtiger schritt den wir damit
machen
ich bitte sie das wieder meine damen und
herren zügig dieses gesetz im deutschen
bundestag beraten und verabschieden
damit wir die weiteren hilfen auch
anweisen können herzlichen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
vielen dank gerne es gern teilen soweit
hubertus heil
hier in der debatte und eröffnet wird
sie von der größten oppositionsfraktion
das ist die afg norbert klein weil ich
da spricht jetzt für sie weiter
präsident sehr geehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen herr minister heil durch die
locker und politik der bundesregierung
hat die regierung dieses land in eine
soziale und wirtschaftliche krise
gestürzt die glaube ich ihresgleichen
sucht sie ist sehr sehr schwer
und was ich ziemlich unredlich finde
herr minister ist dass sie jetzt mit
geld winken und sagen guckt mal wir
haben da eine prämie für euch wir haben
einen bonus wir sind so sozial
meine damen und herren das ist ungefähr
so als wenn sie bei dem wetter
überhöhter geschwindigkeit über die
bundesstraße brettern sie setzen das
auto in die leitplanke und befreien dann
aber nicht ihre mit passagiere sondern
schenken heißen tee aus und sagen
auch bleibt doch bitte sitzen draußen
ist so gefährlich meine damen und herren
machen sie die wirtschaft wieder auf
dann brauchen wir uns über diese almosen
die sie hier verteilen wollen und sich
damit im wahlkampf schmücken nicht
weiter unterhalt und wenn wir wenn wir
das ernsthaft diskutieren im ausschuss
und in den anhörungen was sie heute
vorschlagen dann wirklich nicht weil wir
ihre politik gut finden sondern weil es
darum geht wie man jetzt in diesem
falschen was sie als rahmen gesetzt
haben das richtige tun kann
sie schlagen jetzt zwei große dinge vor
auf der einen seite versuchen sie jetzt
plötzlich da kommen sie auf die idee
einen großen mangeln ihrer eigenen
agenda 2010 zu beheben nämlich dass
menschen die ihre arbeit verlieren
das selbstständige die zum beispiel ihre
geschäftsgrundlage verlieren eben nicht
mehr sozusagen den totalen sozialen
absturz erleben indem sie ihr komplettes
vermögen aufgeben müssen indem ihre
angemessenheit der wohnung überprüft
wird sondern diese überprüfung wird für
einen gewissen zeitraum ausgesetzt und
diese aussetzung möchten sie verlängern
das ist sicherlich sinnvoll aber die
ganz große frage ist warum sie das bis
zum 31 12 2001 21 planen
ich hoffe doch sehr dass sie nicht
planen die wirtschaft bis 31 12 2021
komplett geschlossen zu halten damit
menschen reihenweise in die armut
purzelt in den sozialsystemen ankommen
das wäre wirklich unredlich und es wäre
falsch und deswegen ist die große frage
warum überlassen sie nicht den deutschen
bundestag vielleicht auch den bundestag
der nächsten wahlperiode dann eine
entscheidung wie dieses system weiter
gestaltet werden soll
der zweite große punkt ist ihr bonus
versprechen von 150 euro und übrigens
ihr komplettes gesetzespaket kostet ja
mal geben schlappe 1,4 milliarden euro
das ist nicht nichts halt da stimme ich
ihnen durchaus zu dass es ungefähr das
volumen was ihr im jahr in buffett
ausgeben wo das ist das doppelte
haushaltsvolumen der stadt potsdam und
wenn ich barfuß sage dann ist es sind
wir übrigens bei einem punkt den sie
völlig vergessen also zu den studenten
haben sie nichts geplant von bafög
sonderzahlungen höre ich dich zu haben
vorhin über den kinderbonus diskutiert
in dem steuer hilfe gesetz jetzt
diskutieren wir über 150 euro extra in
den sozialversicherungssystemen sie
versuchen sich ja als guter retter
darzustellen aber sie berücksichtigen
eben nicht alle und genau das ist das
grundproblem sozialistischer politik die
regierung die regierung schafft gar
nicht den kompletten
blick zu behalten sondern es gibt immer
jemanden der durch die masche fällt und
ich bitte sie einfach hier wäre mal die
gelegenheit für einen mantel gesetz
gewesen berücksichtigen sie doch bitte
mal alle betroffenen und führen sie dann
eine ordentliche politik vor beide damen
und herren 150 euro sind ein plakativer
betrag andere würden sagen populismus
nicht wahr
wir sind uns alle einig dass der bedarf
sicherlich steigt für die sozial
schwachen und deswegen sind wir bei
ihnen wenn wir sagen die beträge müssen
erhöht werden aber warum stellen wenn
ich die bedarf für ordentlich fest warum
stellen wir sie nicht empirisch fest
weil so wie sie es machen mit 150 euro
mal pauschal für alle die in den
sozialversicherungssystemen sind und
sich dann als retter aufspielen schaffen
sie neue ungleichheiten zwischen den
kleinen rentner und demjenigen der
weiter grundsicherung ist und von der
einmalzahlung profitiert zwischen den
einen und den anderen zu spielen die
ganze zeit in einen bevölkerungsteil
gegen den anderen aus und das sollte
nicht passieren wir werden uns ihren
vorschlägen widmen aber wie gesagt es
geht hier darum im falschen das richtige
zu tun haben sie herzlichen dank
vielen dank herr kollege klein möchte
norbert klein möchte war das in meine
darüber bereits ihnen jetzt hier einige
argumente bekannt vorkommen einige
maßnahmen die wir eben schon gehört
haben das liegt eben daran dass am
manche bereiche sowohl steuerlich als
auch in der sozialgesetzgebung definiert
werden müssen peter weiß jetzt für die
unionsfraktionen präsident der
kolleginnen kollegen das virus zwingt
uns leider weiter zu maßnahmen im
interesse der gesundheit unserer
mitbürgerin mitbürger auch im interesse
wissen dass unser land seine wirtschaft
auf seine sozialsysteme weiter
funktionieren können zu drastischen
maßnahmen die für viele menschen auch
eine ganz besonders große härte bedeuten
aber die wichtige botschaft ist wir
lassen die menschen in dieser situation
nicht allein
wir lassen sie nicht alleine sondern
treffen helfen und unterstützen mit
einem starken handlungsfähigen und vor
allen dingen auch kommt ziemlich an
einem handlungsfähigen sozialstaat und
genau das ist unsozial schutzpaket 3 und
die sehe ich es richtig dass wir das
heute in den bundestag einbringen
und wer wieder verlieren vor offen sich
zwischen sozial- und sozialismus nicht
unterscheiden kann jetzt natürlich auch
nicht in der lage eine vernünftige
sozialstaats politik zu machen ist denn
der unterschied zur koalition riskant
[Applaus]
wer den kolleginnen kollegen vor allem
noch im blick auf die selbstständigen
dies besonders schwer haben wenn sie
ihre gewohnte tätigkeit nur
eingeschränkt oder gar nicht nachgehen
können verlängern wir zurecht dreimal
den vereinfachten zugang zum
arbeitslosengeld 2 wo wir wohnungen
überprüfung prüfen der wohnsituation
außer acht lassen wo wir großzügig
vermögens grenzen einführen
es ist richtig und notwendig für kinder
die nicht an einer
gemeinschaftsverpflegung in der schule
oder der kita teilnehmen können
verlängern wird die sonderregelung das
auch auf andere art und weise dass der
zuschuss aus dem bildungs und
teilhabepaket zu ihnen kommen kann und
mit dem chor oder zuschuss in höhe von
150 euro und wieder zusätzlich familien
[Musik]
und der minister zurecht auf hingewiesen
wir haben bereits in gang gesetzt dass
es masken gibt und dass vor allen dingen
bei der digitalen end ausstattung wir
eine klare anweisung an die jobcenter
gegeben haben meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren wir wollen explizit nicht und
deswegen helfen wir auch entsprechend
das in dieser krise in der sie wie
digital unterricht notwendig ist weil
präsenz nicht möglich ist es dazu kommt
dass kinder aus ärmeren haushalten
benachteiligt werden nein genau das
gegenteil wir erreichen
[Applaus]
damit soziale dienstleistung und
einrichtungen also das was die soziale
infrastruktur unseres landes ausmacht
in der pandemie nicht in die knie geht
haben wir ja ein völlig neues gesetz
geschaffen mit dem schönen kürzel so
dick dass soziale dienste einsatz
gesetzt und wenn sehr genau und herren
wären wir jetzt mal zu rückblick auf die
vergangenen monate hat es in vielen
fällen geholfen dass dienste und
einrichtungen die zum verschließen
mussten die ihre tätigkeit einschränken
mussten am leben erhalten worden
das betrifft vor allen dingen auch
menschen mit behinderungen deren
werkstätten nur eingeschränkt offen
halten konnten
das betrifft vorsorge und reha
einrichtungen deren belegungszahlen
eingebrochen sind
es betrifft anbieter von leistungen der
arbeitsförderung wurde von sprachkursen
die keine maßnahme durchführen konnten
und und und ich würde sie alles
aufzählen eine beachtliche reihe
und deswegen ist es eine wichtige
botschaft dafür auch die geltung dieses
neuen gesetzes verlängern und ein klares
bekenntnis abgeben wir wollen dass die
dienste die im sozialbereich im
gesundheitsbereich für uns alle da sind
in dieser krise bestehen bleiben und
anschließend hoffentlich mit umso
größerer kraft ihre tätigkeit weiter
betreiben können dieses total
schutzpaket jahr ein klares bekenntnis
zu einer guten und leistungsfähigen
sozialen infrastruktur in unserem land
ja wir sind sie wenn man überhaupt keine
empathie hat in dieser krise wenn man
sich nichts versteht was sind soziale
stadt des landes ausmacht da macht aus
der dumme zwischenrufe wie der jährigen
und noch ein kleiner hinweis
besonders schwer hat es ja gerade auch
diejenigen die als freier künstler ja
normalerweise ihren lohn verdienen
erfolgreich und die nun leider in dieser
krise auch kaum bis gar keine
engagements haben
das ist es wichtig dass wir zusätzliche
regelung treffen dass diese künstlerin
künstler auf jetzt das einkommen
wegfällt mitglieder und
leistungsberechtigte der
künstlersozialkasse bleiben ein klares
bekenntnis wir stehen zu den
künstlerinnen und künstler in unserem
land sie eine zwischenfrage aus
bildschön ja werte herr kollege weiß
ihre kommentare bezüglich meiner
fraktion in meiner person habe ich zur
kenntnis genommen ich darf aber darum
bitten dass sie vielleicht meinen
ausführungen etwas konzentrierter folgen
zukünftig sie hatten ja angemerkt dass
wir angeblich keine sozialen vorschläge
oder keine empathie für die betroffenen
hätten dabei hatte ich meiner rede
eindeutig ausgeführt dass die bedarfe
selbstverständlich gestiegen sind durch
ihre regierungspolitik
selbstverständlich steigen die preise
beispielsweise überall im handel weil
sie gedrucktes geld in den markt pumpen
weil wir damit mittelfristig eine
inflation haben werden
selbstverständlich steigen die ausgaben
gerade für die sozial schwachen menschen
weil sie entsprechend für
hygienemaßnahmen usw
zusätzliche mittel investieren müssen
und ich habe in meiner rede angemerkt
dass wir vielleicht nicht auf einen
plakativen betrag wie 150 euro setzen
sollten sondern dass wir darauf setzen
sollten vielleicht ehrlich den bedarf
neu zu ermitteln
damit wir feststellen
das ist der neue bedarf und der wird
dann auch als bedarf ausgezahlt was
halten sie denn eigentlich von diesem
vorschlag wer hat sie eigentlich auf
diese idee dieser plakativen 150 euro
gebracht wollte hier im
bundestagswahlkampf machen
eine zwischenfrage von iris klein ist es
der achte jetzt begonnen haben zeigt es
dass sie und ihre fraktion einen grossen
fehler im grundverständnis der
derzeitigen situation haben diese krise
ist nicht durch die politik sich durch
das virus ausgelöst und darauf antworten
der politik sehr schön wieder analyse
falsch liegt liegt auch in den
massnahmen falsch ist eine klare
konsequenz wir haben uns zudem frage
nach dem regelsatz im arbeitslosengeld 2
zu kommen
in deutschland ein system was sich
bewährt hat das verfassungsgericht auch
als ein bewertungssystem anerkannt
worden ist nämlich dass wir in
regelmäßigen abständen durch eine
einkommens verbrauchsstichprobe genau
erheben wie kann sich der bedarf einer
einkommensschwachen familien ergeben die
sie ihrem arbeits die wir abbilden in
der finanziellen leistung des
arbeitslosengeldes 2 und genau dieser
prozess hat im vergangenen jahr
stattgefunden und zu lassen januar als
vor etwas mehr als einem monat sind die
neuen regelsätze in kraft getreten
von daher muss ihnen sagen wir haben
bereits das corona jahr 2020 bei der
abbildung dieser regelsätze beachtet und
vielleicht ist ihnen das entgangen dass
wir im deutschen bundestag des neuen
regelsätze in einem gesetz miteinander
geschlossen haben
jetzt sitzen sie schon darüber noch
hinzufügen das gesetz sieht auch vor
hoch das war auch einmalige mehrbedarfe
mit berücksichtigen darf und kann
wir bewegen uns also auch mit 150 euro
voll und ganz in der systematik des
sozialgesetzbuches 2 wir brauchen das
gesetz nicht auseinander geben ist ein
gutes gesetz es ist wirkt und es gibt es
auch instrument in der hand in
sondersituationen angemessen zu
reagieren
wer die kolleginnen kollegen des
sozialismus partie 2 ist eine klare
botschaft ein klares angebot wir stehen
an der seite der menschen die es in
dieser krise besonders hart haben wir
helfen mit einem handlungsfähigen auf
allen dingen einen handlungsfähigen
sozialstaat vielen dank der lenker wurde
gewisser weise war das und hier noch mal
kurze erläuterung dass er angesprochen
hat das norbert kleinwächter sich schon
hingesetzt hat das ist hier usus wenn
jemand eine zwischenfrage stellt das
dann der fragende die fragen der so
lange stehen bis sie beantwortet ist
das kann aber natürlich auch mal
passieren dass man denkt dass sie schon
beantwortet ist und man sich deswegen
hinsetzt pascal kober spricht jetzt für
die fdp
der bundesminister sie haben ein
gesetzentwurf vorgelegt mit dem sie eine
einmal zahlung vorsehen für
grundsicherungsempfänger erwachsene
grundsicherungsempfänger von 150 euro
was sie hier aber nicht explizit gesagt
haben ist dass sie diese einmalzahlung
ja erst im mai auszahlen werden was ist
das für ein trauriges liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen die menschen brauchen jetzt
finanzielle unterstützung um sich jetzt
in der hochphase der pandemie schützen
zu können
liebe kollegen und kolleginnen jetzt ist
die zeit in menschen oder die arme zu
greifen und nicht erst im mai und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir haben unter diesen
grundsicherungsempfänger wohlhabende
personen
wir haben menschen in der grundsicherung
die die möglichkeit haben müssen im
nächstgelegenen supermarkt statt im
günstigsten einkaufen zu müssen
wir haben menschen mit behinderung in
der grundsicherung die zu mit
vorerkrankungen zu den wohlhabenden
gruppen gehören die brauchen jetzt die
finanzielle unterstützung und nicht erst
im mai und deshalb ist dieser
gesetzentwurf unzureichend deshalb
werden wir ihn auch in dieser form
ablehnen
lieber bundesminister ich habe sie schon
im märz darauf hingewiesen dass im
schreiben dass die lebensmittelpreise
ansteigen ich habe sie im märz schon
darauf hingewiesen dass es mit
sicherheit zu einer unterdeckung bei der
grundsicherung gekommen sein dürfte sie
haben nicht reagiert jetzt kommen sie
nach einem jahr pandemie und ledigen den
menschen einen vorschlag vor der sie im
mai erster erreichen soll lieber aktiv
das ist in keinster weise soziale
verantwortung das ist wirklich eine
ablehnung sozialer verantwortung die wir
ihnen nicht durchgehen lassen dürfen
die sozialen träger die peter weiss
angeschrieben hat angesprochen hat in
der tat wir brauchen unsere soziale
infrastruktur in diesem land aber die
soziale infrastruktur in unserem land
braucht auch eine perspektive und zwar
eine perspektive über wenige monate
hinaus und der saal ist es unzureichend
im gesetz die unterstützung des sodexo
bis zum juni festzuschreiben
wir hätten hier eine langfristige
perspektive gebraucht weil wir die
soziale infrastruktur auch dauerhaft
brauchen und die mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter in den sozialen
einrichtungen diese langfristige
perspektive auch brauchen
der kollege kurve erlauben seine
zwischen frage des abgeordneten
er glaubt die frage herr kollege ja sehr
geehrter herr kollege kober ganz
herzlichen dank dass ich inzwischen
frage zu lassen sie wissen dass ich sie
menschlich und fachlich sehr schätze
aber ich bitte im rahmen dieser zwischen
marco mainz zur kenntnis zu nehmen
ich lasse nicht zu dass sie hier
unredlich über den parlamentarismus
reden
die bundesregierung ist nicht in der
lage geld über eine handkasse
auszuzahlen sondern sie brauchen eine
gesetzgeberische grundlage deshalb
bringen wir dieses gesetz ein
ich habe das vor 14 tagen angekündigt
wir haben im koalitionsausschuss letzte
woche beschlossen heute ist der
gesetzentwurf im deutschen bundestag und
wenn sie die frage ob das im mai
ausgezahlt würde hier skandalisieren
kann ich ihnen sagen
dann stimmen sie besser schnell zu dann
sorgen sie dafür dass wir das schnell
machen können und wenn sie den menschen
und das schlagen
das ist nicht nur ein gesetz braucht
sondern bei schnellen hilfen auch eine
gute administration die wir mit den
jobcentern und den der bundesagentur
haben sie sehen das ja bei den
wirtschaftswegen hat der kollege
altmaier keine bundesverwaltung in der
fläche deshalb dauert das lange und
manchmal auch sehr lange wir haben da
gute bundesagentur habe gute jobcenter
wenn es nach mir geht geht das auch
alles viel viel schneller aber die
menschen hinter die fichte zu führen
eben so zu tun als braucht es kein
gesetz dafür das finde ich mehr als
unredlich sie wissen es besser und
deshalb kann ich nur sagen dass das hier
machen des populismus und nichts anderes
sehr geehrter herr bundesminister auch
ich schätze sie menschlich ohne zweifel
wir wissen dass voneinander aber hier
komme ich zu einer fachlich sachlich
anderen einschätzung und auch über diese
einschätzung habe ich sie im märz
vergangenen jahres nicht im unklaren
gelassen ich glaube dass der park 26 es
über eine mehrbedarfs regelung einfach
gemacht hätte tatsächlich den menschen
eine schnelle hilfe vorzulegen und
selbst wenn es dann im ergebnis zu einem
gesetz hätte kommen müssen oder kommen
sollte dann hätten sie natürlich zeit
gehabt in den vergangenen fast zwölf
monaten dieses gesetz auf den weg zu
bringen
und jetzt reagieren sie im februar sie
haben zu recht gesagt vor zwei wochen
haben sie das vorgelegt jetzt reagieren
sie im februar aber planen die
auszahlung erst im mai und dieser lange
zusammenhang den können sie keinen
erklären ich sage lieber herr
bundesminister heilige hubertus das
hätte schneller gehen könnt vor allen
dingen hätte es schneller gehen müssen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen es ist
wie ich gerade ausgeführt habe nicht die
zeit deal für die zukunft schreiben
sondern es ist die zeit dass wir jetzt
reagieren und deshalb herr
bundesminister fassen sie sich ein herz
prüfen sie den vorschlag ist immer der
bedarfs- regelung auszubezahlen
ich bin zuversichtlich dass das
tatsächlich in der sache möglich wäre
und das zweite was wichtig ist und auch
noch mal angesprochen werde werden muss
ist dass sie ja nach wie vor
künstlerinnen und künstler
kulturschaffende solo selbstständige in
die grundsicherung verweisen obwohl ja
eigentlich ein eigenes system angemessen
gewesen wäre
hier wären vorschlag aus ihrem hause
hilfreich und auch da haben sie bisher
nicht geliefert
also hier noch eine kurze zwischenfrage
von dem minister der um eben diese
frisch zwischenfrage stellen zu können
dann das als abgeordneter tun muss
deswegen hat er das hier aus den reihen
seiner fraktion gemacht und ist nicht im
auf der regierungsbank sitzen geblieben
katja kipping spricht jetzt für die in
linksfraktion
herr präsident meine damen und herren
wir reden heute hier über eine einmalige
zahlung von 150 euro an die ärmsten im
land und die fdp schreit auf als wäre
das schon sozialismus als vorsitzender
einer demokratisch sozialistischen
partei kann ich nur sagen das wasserwerk
zu sein hier geliefert hat das jetzt
wahrlich nicht sozialistisch es ist noch
nicht mal konsequent sozialen denn beim
schutz der ernsten handelt diese
regierung zu spät und halbherzig
seit der ersten woche corona krise haben
wir darauf hingewiesen dass diese krise
natürlich mehr ausgaben verursacht bei
den ernsten nicht nur für masken und
desinfektionsmittel im lockdown vielen
nothilfen weg günstige
einkaufsmöglichkeiten fallen weg wenn
die kitas und schulen geschlossen sind
fällt das gestützte das kostenlose
mittagessen weg wenn die kinder den
ganzen tag zu hause sind fällt natürlich
mehrkosten für strom kommunikation
druckerpatronen bastelmaterialien und
und und und vielleicht hätten jetzt
einige von ihnen sagen das ist ja ganz
schön klein kariert was die aufzählt mit
bastelmaterialien und strom usw aber für
menschen die auf hartz iv angewiesen
sind
die jeden euro zweimal umdrehen müssen
ist das eben ein problem und deswegen
sage ich ganz klar abgeordnete und
regierende die müssen nicht jeden euro
dreimal umdrehen
aber sie müssen immer die wirklichkeit
und die sorgen haben
im blick haben die das tun müssen
zusammen mit einem breiten bündnis von
41 sozialverbänden und gewerkschaften
fordern wir deshalb ein corona zuschlag
auf sozialleistungen auf sozial wenden
und über welche menschen reden wir hier
um das noch einmal zu verdeutlichen
wir reden über geringverdienende wie zum
beispiel alleinerziehende die
aufstockung platz 4 beantragen müssen
über arme rentnerinnen und rentner über
die bewerber über menschen die in
werkstätten für behinderte arbeiten
langzeiterwerbslose pflegebedürftig
erwerbsgeminderte und und rund elf
monate lang hat die regierung dieses
thema ignoriert und das bedeutet er für
diese menschen elf monate zusätzliche
existenznöte
das hätten wir den ersparen können wenn
die cdu eher bereit gewesen wer etwas
für die ärmsten zu tun und sie handeln
halbherzig weil es ist nur eine
einmalige zahlung die kosten fallen aber
jeden monat an und deswegen in aller
deutlichkeit vor den wir als linke
mindestens 100 euro ohne zuschlag für
jeden corona monat und das auch
rückwirkend
ich möchte abschließend noch etwas
grundsätzliches sagen weil die korona
krise ja schon auch offen legt wo noch
schwachstellen sind wo unser bisheriges
sozialsystem nicht funktioniert für
prekär beschäftigte minijob der
freischaffende honorarkräfte
kunstschaffende für aldi gibt es keine
garantierten sozialen schutz und
deswegen lautet die richtige konsequenz
aus der korona krise es ist zeit für
eine sanktionsfreie mindestsicherung
damit niemand im notfall unter 1200 euro
im monat fällt vielen dank katja kipping
bades ja bekannt als parteivorsitzende
der linken aber hier im deutschen
bundestag hat sie eben auch die rolle
der sozialpolitischen sprecherin
hier in der debatte zum sozialschutz
paket 3 und der nächste redner ist es
wenn lehmann muss 90 die grünen
herr präsident lieber kolleginnen
kollegen in der tat haben in dieser
woche 41 gewerkschaften sozial
wohlfahrtsverbände kinderschutz
familienverbände der verband der tafeln
und viele viele mehr
in einem eindringlichen appell erneut
deutlich gemacht dass für einen
aufschlag auf die grundsicherung
brauchen um erneut deutlich zu machen
dass die ärmsten in dieser krise nicht
noch ärmer werden dürfen
100 euro jeden monat mehr für erwachsene
60 euro für kinder
wir grüne schließen uns dieser forderung
an wir haben das mehrfach hier beantragt
wir werden es immer wieder beantragen
das ist dieser bundestag endlich
beschließt die kollegen kollegen was
machen jetzt cdu csu und spd mit diesem
gesetzentwurf stadt auch die fachwelt zu
hören 150 euro einmalzahlung
wir haben seit einem jahr diese krise
wir haben in dieser zeit ist geschafft
und auch mit großen mehrheiten
milliarden schwere hilfspaket hier auf
den weg zu bringen das war richtig aber
die ärmsten sind quasi leer ausgegangen
und jetzt gibt es nach einem jahr 150
euro einmalzahlung für einen erwachsenen
menschen
ich hätte ehrlich gesagt erwartet dass
sie das hier tot schweigen weil es so
peinlich ist aber stattdessen ruhe sich
noch dafür das ist nicht mehr als ein
wahltaktisches almosen wir brauchen
echte hilfen für die menschen der
grundsicherung liebe kolleginnen
kollegen und jetzt sagt minister habe
deutlich so tun als wenn das nichts
150 euro einmalzahlung
über 13 monate sind etwa elf euro 50 pro
monat und sind 38 cent pro tag der
regelsatz ist schon viel zu niedrig und
jetzt kommen lächerliche 38 cent pro tag
bei steigenden preisen für obst für
gemüse für frische lebensmittel für
energie für desinfektionsmittel und und
und das ist keine hilfe das ist eine
nullrunde für die armen und das müssten
sie sich auch hier vorwerfen lassen
herr minister und jetzt wird damit
begonnen 10 fsp zwei masken für menschen
in der grundsicherung kostenlos zu
organisieren dass es gut aber es ist ja
wohl auch das mindeste wenn das schon
als pflicht auch besteht
und jetzt stellt sich heraus dass das zb
für geflüchtete seitens der
bundesregierung gar nicht vorgesehen ist
hier verweist die bundesregierung an die
länder und kommunen ich habe diese woche
noch schriftlich bekommen dann
infektionsschutz besteht also nicht nur
ein flickenteppich sondern auch ein
klassensystem infektionsschutz da aber
weder vom geldbeutel noch vom
aufenthaltsstatus abhängig ist für alle
menschen gelten wieder kolleginnen
kollegen
ich komme zum schluss die korona krise
ist groß ja und deswegen müssen die
reaktion auch sozialpolitisch große 1
dieses dritte sozialschutz paket ist es
leider nicht
ja sie verlängern einige regelungen beim
zugang zur grundsicherung sie verlängert
die sicherstellung der sozialen dienste
bis ende juni da frag ich mich ehrlich
gesagt warum nur bis ende juni
die krise wird wohl kaum bis ende juni
vorbei sein und gerade die träger in der
sozialpolitik brauchen eine
längerfristige sicherheit das heißt es
braucht an diesem gesetzentwurf noch
deutlicher verbesserungen dazu sind wir
bereit und werden das auch in den
ausschuss anhörungen auch entsprechende
anträge deutlich machen vielen dank für
ihre aufmerksamkeit
vielen dank so das präsidium hat
gewechselt dagmar ziegler führt jetzt
hier diese leitung sie ist ja für die
spd hier gekommen in diese position
nachdem thomas oppermann verstorben ist
dagmar schmidt spricht jetzt für die
sozialdemokraten präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen lieber sven
lehmann
man muss schon einen abgeordneten gehalt
haben um 150 euro nicht viel geld zu
finden
ich finde das ziemlich zynisch das so
hier zu sagen es gibt ganz viele
menschen für sie sind 150 euro viel geld
dann wenn ich eine familie habe mit zwei
erwachsenen und zwei kindern bekomme 600
euro wenn ich sonst auf grundsicherung
angewiesen bin dann ist das viel geld
und ich finde zynisches etwas anderes zu
behaupten immer mehr das geht aber zu
sagen das wäre nichts das ist nicht in
ordnung
kolleginnen und kollegen die pandemie
belastet uns alle
es macht aber eben ein unterschied ob
das gehalt in der pandemie weiter
gezahlt wird oder ob das eigene geschäft
gerade keinen umsatz hat es macht einen
unterschied ob man sozial abgesichert
ist oder ob man gerade mit wenig oder
sehr wenig geld auskommen muss es macht
einen unterschied ob man einen job
suchen muss in dieser situation ob man
kinder hat oder eltern pflegt auf
betreuung wegfällt und man homeschooling
organisieren muss und deswegen ist es
wichtig und richtig immer wieder zu
gucken
und während der pandemie die
unterstützung auch immer wieder
anzupassen um eben möglichst viele zu
erreichen deswegen bin ich froh dass wir
mit dem sozial schutzpaket drei heute
wieder einen wichtigen beitrag dazu
leisten
erstens wir verlängern den schutz für
die sozialen dienstleister und ich hoffe
dass wir da zu einer unkomplizierten
regelung kommen die das auch verlässlich
bis wirklich zum ende der pandemie wann
auch immer das sein wird das
gewährleiste zweitens wir verlängern was
wir gerne auch grundsätzlich so hätten
den einfachen zugang zur grundsicherung
und sicherheit in schwierigen
lebenssituationen arbeitslosigkeit und
das gilt nicht nur für zeiten der
pandemie ist in den seltensten fällen
ein selbst gewähltes schicksal und der
grundsicherung beantragt darf keine
angst haben sofort sein erspartes oder
seine wohnung zu verlieren wir wollen
eine brücke bauen in die zeiten nach der
pandemie und sicherheit geben damit eben
der kopf frei ist für einen job suchen
damit der kopf frei ist für einen
neuanfang und einen neustart und diese
brücke verlängern wir und tritt ist ja
das ist richtig wir müssen uns noch mehr
um familien kümmern eltern allen voran
mutter gerade aber auch die kinder und
die jugendlichen tragen eine ganz
besondere last in dieser pandemie und
deswegen bin ich froh dass wir erneut
ein kinderbonus von 150 euro pro kind
beschlossen schließen werden wir haben
das eben diskutiert denn die
möglichkeiten einer familie mit der
krise umzugehen sind eben auch abhängig
von ihren finanziellen möglichkeiten und
gerade diejenigen die es sowieso schon
schwer haben sind in einer krise noch
mal stärker belastet und betroffen und
ist deswegen ist es richtig und es ist
auch an der zeit für diejenigen die
grundsicherungsleistungen erhalten mit
freien ffp zwei masken kinder laptops
für die schulen usw dem aufschlag von
150 euro endlich ein ausgleich zu
schaffen ich möchte aber gerne noch
etwas deutlich dazu sagen nicht nur
diejenigen die grundsicherungsleistung
erhalten haben es schwer wir haben für
menschen die arbeiten und wo es trotzdem
nicht reicht zwei bausteine im
sozialstaat der eine ist das wohngeld
der andere ist der kinderzuschlag und
ich würde mich freuen wenn diejenigen
die wohngeld oder kinderzuschlag
bekommen auch ein zuschuss von 150 euro
bekämen vielleicht können wir da ja noch
etwas gemeinsam erreichen
schutz und sicherheit ein sozialstaat
der flexibel ist lernt und einfach hilft
das bleibt unser ziel
in der pandemie und danach vielen dank
für ihre aufmerksamkeit
sagt mal schmeckt würdig für die
sozialdemokraten und damit kommen wir
hier zum letzten redner in dieser
debatte das ist stephan stracke vorsitz
unter anderem ausschuss für arbeit und
soziales präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren die
wirtschaftlichen folgen des virus sind
massiv und auch die sozialen und
psychischen schäden sind hoch und wir
tun alles dieser koalition um diese
schäden abzufedern die wirtschaftlichen
sozialen folgen für die menschen
abzufedern
und dabei haben wir die gefahren dieses
virus es nie unterschätzt hengst die
grundausrichtung und die strategie
innerhalb dieser bundesregierung war
immer richtig anders als andere mussten
wir uns nicht korrigieren
ich denke beispielsweise erste
präsidentin ramelow das auch öffentlich
zugegeben hat es verdient natürlich auch
respekt so was auch zu geben zu können
aber letztendlich aber letztendlich
braucht es weitsicht und klugheit was
die nächsten schritte angeht und
weitsicht und klugheit vermisse ich
insbesondere bei den vorschlägen der afd
all das was sie jetzt fordern ist der
sichere weg in die dritte welle und eine
dritte welle bedeutet mehr schäden
dramatische schäden in wirtschaft und im
sozialen bereich und natürlich auch mehr
tote das wollen wir nicht und deswegen
gehen wir sehr konsequent unseren kurs
von vorsicht und umsicht fort und das
ist auch das richtige rezept wie wir
jetzt mit diesem virus insgesamt umgehen
müssen
der pflege geben sie
dazwischen wird an frau katja kipping
von der linksfraktion hat eine
zwischenfrage strecke vielen dank für
die möglichkeit eine zwischenfrage zu
stellen sie haben gesagt sie tun alles
um die folgen abzufedern
jetzt ist ja im raum der vorschlag dass
diese einmalige zahlung was uns zu wenig
ist als linke aber dass wenigstens diese
kleine zahlung auch an bezieher von
wohngeld und kinderzuschlag gehen soll
und für alle die mit diesem
sozialpolitischen fachbegriff nicht so
viel zu tun haben das sind menschen die
ein extrem geringes alterseinkommen
haben oder familien mit mehreren kindern
die auf ein ganz geringes einkommen
haben bei denen abzufedern
bisher steht das nicht im
gesetzesentwurf es gibt das böse gerücht
es würde an der cdu liegen jetzt habe
ich sie ganz persönlich um mir mal
transparenz zu schaffen
was halten sie denn persönlich von der
idee diese kleine leistung die uns als
linke natürlich zu klein ist auch auf
vielleicht die 600.000 betroffenen
wohngeld beziehen und kinderzuschlag
beziehen auszuweiten
frau kollegin kipping ich finde dass
diese einmalzahlung die wir jetzt auf
den weg bringen wollen mit 150 euro eine
sehr pragmatische antwort ist auf den
mehrbedarf der sich hier darstellt
gerade im bereich dieser pandemie und
auch einer der sehr unbürokratisch auf
den weg gebracht werden kann
deswegen unterstütze ich ausdrücklich
dass wir diese einmalzahlung jetzt auf
den weg bringen und dass wir das auch
letztendlich machen indem er ja auch aus
ihrem bereich dass sie die regelsätze
gerne anpacken wollen und da unter uns
stehen monatliche zahlungen haben wollen
sie haben sie in ihrer rede benannt
gehabt ich will da nur erinnern dass wir
im rahmen der veränderung und der
weiterentwicklung der grundsicherung der
regelsätze ja sehr wohl sehr wohl ich
komm schon darauf sehr wohl die
preisentwicklungen dieses dieses
pandemie jahr 2020 berücksichtigt haben
das zum einen und dabei auch die
mehrwertsteuersenkung im übrigen die ein
halbes jahr galt nicht berücksichtigt
haben das zeigte gesamtschau in dem wir
uns bewegen und deswegen
müssten wir jetzt diskutieren darüber
und das tun wir nicht nur haben dieses
parlamentes sondern auch außerhalb ob es
noch weitere ansatzpunkte gibt diese 150
euro beispielsweise zu verlängern
ich verschließe mich einer solchen
diskussion sehr verehrten damen und
herren um letztlich diese pandemie mit
ihren wirtschaftlichen folgen in den
griff zu bekommen ist unser deutsche
sozialstaat ein stabiler schutz und
schirm in dieser naturkatastrophe lassen
niemanden allein und wer hilfe braucht
dann unterstützen wir
wir haben deswegen in der letzten woche
ein zehn milliarden euro paket geschnürt
mit mehr unterstützung für unternehmen
für familien und für menschen mit wenig
geld die besonders unter dieser krise
leiden und wir haben wir beispielsweise
mit dem kurzarbeitergeld ja schon eine
sehr stabile regelung was beschäftigung
und liquidität in den betrieben angeht
mit dem aufgestockten kurzarbeitergeld
geben wir auch einen deutlichen beitrag
zur sicherung der kaufkraft und menschen
die es besonders schwer haben auf dem
arbeitsmarkt trifft natürlich diese
pandemie in besonderer art und weise und
deswegen haben wir dafür gesorgt bereits
im frühjahr des vergangenen jahres den
zugang zu den grund sicherungssystemen
deutlich zu erleichtern und schnell und
einfach die notwendigen finanzielle
unterstützung zu organisieren niemanden
lassen wir in existenzieller not alleine
deswegen verlängern wir diese regelungen
das ist sicherlich gut die einmalzahlung
ist eine pragmatische antwort darauf
habe ich ja bereits hingewiesen und
schlüsselfrage da auch noch einmal die
forderungen die ja hier von grünen und
der sp und der linken insbesondere
kommen was das bedingungslose
grundeinkommen angeht schlüsselfrage ist
nicht
möglichst hohen geldleistungen möglichst
lange in der grundsicherung zu behandeln
ist nicht die schlüsselfrage
schlüsselfrage ist vor allem das ist
eine arbeitsmarktpolitische aufgabe wie
wir möglichst schnell aus dem bezug
wieder herauskommen das ist letztendlich
auch etwas was den menschen gerecht wird
sie nicht möglichst lange von
grundsicherung leben zu lassen sondern
möglichst schnell wieder herauszuholen
darauf konzentrieren uns unsere bemühung
wenn man diese einmalzahlungen von 150
euro sieht dann ist es ja im gesamtpaket
zu sehen mit der bereitstellung von
kostenfreien ffp zwei masken mit der
übernahme der kosten für digitale
endgeräte bis zu 350 euro damit kinder
am online unterricht auch teilnehmen
können
ausdruck der vorsorge ist es ein warmes
mittagessen für kinder und jugendliche
zu organisieren wenn es wieder pandemie
bedingt zu schließungen kommen sollte
wir hoffen dass dies nicht der fall ist
und gleiches gilt natürlich auch für die
sozialen dienste und einrichtungen wir
wollen die soziale infrastruktur
schützen wir kümmern uns also um die
sozial schwächsten in unserer
gesellschaft und um die kümmerer in den
sozialen diensten und einrichtungen und
das zeigt unser sozialstaat ist
leistungsfähig und hat dem stresstest in
dieser pandemie mehr als bestanden meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren und eins
ist noch wichtig kunst und
kulturschaffende sie sind systemrelevant
und deswegen ist es auch ein wichtiges
signal das wir aussenden dass wir für
diese hier die das jährliche mindest
einkommensgrenze auch im jahr 20 21
aussetzen die künstlersozialversicherung
bietet einen wichtigen schutz gerade für
diese wichtige gruppe derer die im kunst
und kultur unglaublich leisten und
deswegen darf dieser schutz nicht
verloren gehen dafür sorgen wir
insgesamt ein gutes gesetzgebungs paket
das wir als koalition auf den weg
bringen wollen
die einseitige zustimmung und
unterstützung vielen dank
interfraktionell wird überweist und das
war jetzt also die rede dazu zum sozial
schutzpaket dass dieser gesetzentwurf
wird jetzt an die entsprechenden
ausschüsse überwiesen federführend ist
er aber der ausschuss für arbeit und
soziales allerdings wird in diesem thema
auch der haushaltsausschuss dort noch
mal besonders beraten
auch dabei seien in den debatten